Bonjour!
Pour ce 6e Gentes Dames Badass je vais vous
parler d'une femme que j'ai découverte par
hasard, à la radio, alors que je traversais
la Comté en voiture.
Parce que oui, on a un village dans les Hauts
de France qui s'appelle la Comté.
Bref, rien à voir.
Gertrude Bell est une personne que je trouve
absolument passionnante, même si tous les
aspects de sa personnalité ne me plaisent
pas, et on va donc parler aujourd'hui d'Angleterre
victorienne, de Moyen-Orient, d'empire Ottoman
sur fond de première guerre mondiale...
Bref, on va voyager.
Gertrude Bell naît le 14 juillet 1868 en
Angleterre, dans une famille bien bien riche.
La 6e fortune d'Angleterre, en gros, qui s'est
enrichie grâce à l'industrie et notamment
la forge.
Elle étudie au Queen's College de Londres,
puis entre à Oxford à 16 ans où elle obtient
son diplôme d'Histoire moderne en seulement
deux ans, au lieu de trois.
Ça, plus le fait qu'elle soit la première
à obtenir une mention très bien dans cette
discipline filles et garçons confondus, ça
marque un peu les esprits au point que la
presse parle d'elle.
Gertrude était intelligente, voire surdouée,
passionnée d'Histoire, de diplomatie et de
politique.
A l'époque où elle étudie, à la fin des
années 80, elle n'est pas la seule fille
à Oxford et les rares étudiantes sont plutôt
bien acceptées là-bas, sauf par quelques
professeurs qui continuent de ne pas trop
tolérer cette présence féminine et exigent
que les étudiantes leur tournent le dos pendant
les cours.
Gertrude est aussi toujours accompagnée d'un
chaperon, pendant ses études, parce qu'elle
reste une fille de la haute société victorienne
et ne peut pas faire n'importe quoi.
Et évidemment, être intelligente dans les
années 1890, pour une femme, c'était pas
très bien perçu.
Même si elle est persuadée que ses diplômes
ne seront pas un handicap au moment de se
chercher un mari: spoiler, c'en est un.
Pourtant, elle est aussi très belle, sportive,
et rousse, ce qui est déjà un signe de qualité
formidable.
Le problème avec Gertrude, c'est qu'en plus
d'être intelligente, elle n'hésite pas à
le montrer.
Par exemple lors de ce dîner de diplomates,
où elle reprend devant tout le monde un ambassadeur
allemand qui avait employé un mauvais terme
de géopolitique.
A 20 ans.
Même si ses parents la soutiennent pas mal,
ils lui envoient quelques lettres bien senties
après cet événement, et elle se met à
adopter un peu mieux un comportement de lady.
Faute de mari mais ayant envie de voyages,
elle part à l'aventure en Amérique, Pacifique,
Chine, Japon, Perse.....
Elle parle persan, hindou, ourdou, japonais,
arabe, turc, allemand, français, pratique
aussi la photographie et l'alpinisme.
Elle était d'une grande résistance physique,
et réalise la traversée et l'escalade de
plusieurs montagnes des Alpes.
L'une d'entre elles, le Gertrudspitze, est
d'ailleurs baptisée en son honneur.
Elle s'amuse donc beaucoup, mais comme c'est
une femme et qu'elle est riche, tous ces voyages
ne lui permettent pas d'avoir un métier.
D'autres personnes ayant fait les mêmes études
et voyagé autant qu'elle seraient déjà
archéologues, diplomates, explorateurs...
Si c'étaient des hommes.
En 1895, elle rencontre David Hogarth, le
mec au milieu, à gauche de Lawrence d'Arabie.
Il est lui-même archéologue et co-créateur
des services de renseignements britanniques.
Il lui suggère alors de voyager vers l'empire
Ottoman, et ça change pas mal sa vie.
Après s'être formée à l'archéologie,
elle se met à voyager.
Pendant dix ans, elle parcourt le désert,
découvre l'ancienne Mésopotamie, la Palestine,
la Syrie, l'Arabie...
Elle monte six expéditions, et s'attache
à chaque fois à rencontrer les populations
du désert, qui l'intéressent plus que les
vieilles pierres.
Elle voyage donc de tribu en tribu, dressant
son campement près des camps bédouins, envoyant
ensuite sa carte de visite au cheik, pour
ensuite l'inviter ou être reçue par lui
pour boire le thé et discuter de poésie
dans le plus grand des calmes.
Elle est fascinée par le mode de vie des
bédouins, qui vivent dans des campements
de 60, 70 tentes tout de même, et les cheiks
la voient comme une ambassadrice de son pays
même si officiellement elle ne l'est pas.
Faut dire qu'elle ne voyage pas n'importe
comment: elle est toujours accompagnée
de 6 à 8 hommes dont Fatou, son second qui
la suit dans la plupart de ses expéditions,
et garde en toutes circonstances son corset,
ses jupons dans lesquels elle planque des
armes, voyage avec son argenterie, ses nappes
brodées, sa baignoire...
Elle reste une lady, et même si elle est
sincèrement attachée aux codes victoriens,
se montrer comme une lady lui permet d'asseoir
sa légitimité tout en brisant certains codes
quand ils ne vont pas dans son sens.
J'ouvre une parenthèse, qui constitue le
seul point qui me déplaît chez elle: elle
était tellement victorienne qu'elle était
opposée aux suffragettes et faisait même
partie d'une ligue anti, avant tout parce
qu'elle trouvait les suffragettes vulgaires.
Enfin bref: en rencontrant les cheiks, elle
obtient aussi de nombreuses informations:
elle apprend qui est marié à qui, qui est
allié avec qui...
Et chaque fois qu'elle rentre en Angleterre,
elle va rendre visite à David Hogarth pour
lui rapporter tout ce qu'elle a appris.
Elle n'était donc pas officiellement un agent
de renseignements, n'était pas payée pour
ça ni couverte par le Royaume-Uni en cas
de pépin, mais agissait comme tel.
Grâce à ses voyages elle informe les renseignements
sur les tensions entre les tribus, mais aussi
la présence grandissante des allemands dans
l'empire Ottoman, qui achètent de nombreuses
concessions archéologiques et construisent
des chemins de fer à travers le désert.
En 1907, elle découvre les ruines de la cité
mésopotamienne d'Ekalte, et participe à
de nombreuses autres fouilles au cours de
ses voyages.
Elle s'est acquise une solide réputation
en Angleterre et dans la région, où on la
surnomme «la dame de Bagdad» ou «la
khatun».
C'est au cours de l'un de ses voyages, en
1911, qu'elle fait la connaissance d'un autre
archéologue et diplomate que vous connaissez
probablement tous: Thomas Edward Lawrence,
alias Lawrence d'Arabie.
A l'époque il est second sur un chantier
de fouilles dirigé par David Hogarth, et
les deux s'entendent tout de suite très bien
puisqu'ils partagent la passion de l'Orient
et du danger.
Gertrude lui apprend d'ailleurs beaucoup de
choses sur les tribus arabes, puisqu'elle
a un peu plus d'expérience que lui.
Elle entame son voyage le plus dangereux en
1913, lorsqu'elle décide de s'enfoncer dans
la péninsule arabique, alors très dangereuse
puisque trois tribus bédouines se disputent
le territoire.
Le gouvernement britannique refuse de la soutenir
mais elle part quand même, et est brièvement
faite prisonnière en février 1914 avant
d'être relâchée et de pouvoir fuir vers
le nord.
Elle prend cette expédition comme un échec,
et deux mois après son retour la guerre éclate,
ce qui empêche bien sûr toute nouvelle expédition.
Elle s'engage donc dans la Croix Rouge en
France, mais vit une période difficile déjà
parce qu'elle voudrait retourner au Moyen-Orient,
et ensuite parce que l'homme marié qu'elle
aimait de manière platonique meurt à la
guerre en 1915.
Mais heureusement pour elle, ses amis se souviennent
d'elle et lui demandent en 1915 d'intégrer
les service secrets du Caire, grâce à ses
super connaissances du Moyen-Orient et surtout
du désert du Nefoud, celui qu'elle a traversé
pendant son expédition la plus dangereuse.
En plus, elle avait déjà le meilleur réseau
sur place.
C'est là que je fais un point «Empire
Ottoman», aussi surnommé «l'homme malade
de l'Europe» par le reste du monde: déjà
avant 1914, l'empire allait mal.
Les grandes puissances européennes s'efforçaient
de le maintenir en vie par peur du bordel
que ça allait devenir s'il disparaissait,
mais commençaient aussi à tâter le terrain
pour la suite des événements.
C'est pourquoi les anglais étaient très
bien positionnés puisqu'ils étaient en Égypte,
en Mésopotamie et en Inde, et c'est aussi
pourquoi les allemands s'y montraient de plus
en plus présents.
Avec le déclenchement de la guerre, tout
le monde pressent donc le bordel que va devenir
cette région.
Au Caire, Gertrude retrouve Lawrence d'Arabie
dont le projet est de s'allier avec les tribus
arabes, notamment les hachémites, pour attaquer
les turcs par le sud.
Elle lui fournit donc pas mal d'informations
sur les tribus à contacter et leurs emplacements,
et le reste, vous en auriez un aperçu en
regardant le film de David Lean.
Pendant que Lawrence fait ses affaires dans
la péninsule, elle est envoyée à Bassorah
où elle dessine des cartes en tant qu'officier
de liaison, puis à Bagdad.
Le problème est qu'en échange de l'aide
des tribus arabes, Gertrude Bell et Lawrence
avaient promis une nation à ces tribus.
C'était dans l'air du temps en 1915, mais
en 1916 les accords secrets de Sykes-Picot
partagent le Proche-Orient entre la France
et le Royaume-Uni.
Peu de gens étaient au courant de ces accords,
révélés au public en 1917, et même s'ils
ne sont finalement pas vraiment appliqués
Gertrude et Lawrence ont le sentiment d'avoir
trahi les populations concernées.
Tous deux sont pour l'indépendance des peuples
arabes, et le font savoir.
En 1919, Gertrude rédige un rapport sur la
Mésopotamie et commence à parler du futur
Irak et de qui pourrait le gouverner.
En 1921, elle est conseillère de Churchill
lors de la conférence internationale du Caire,
dans le camp des orientalistes: ceux qui
défendent les intérêts des arabes.
On la voit ici, avec Churchill et Lawrence.
Toujours en 1921, elle et Lawrence dessinent
les nouvelles frontières de ce qui devient
l'Irak.
Ce nouveau pays est destiné aux hachémites,
puisqu'ils ont aidé le Royaume-Uni pendant
la guerre, et Gertrude insiste pour mettre
sur le trône Fayçal Ier d'Irak.
Dans la même foulée est créée la Transjordanie.
Bien sûr, confier ces pays à des locaux
reste dans l'intérêt du Royaume-Uni, qui
vise principalement les champs de pétrole
sur ces territoires, mais son intervention
a été décisive.
Après la création de l'Irak, elle conseille
le roi Fayçal au début de son règne, ce
qui lui vaut le surnom de «reine sans couronne
d'Irak». Elle est très attachée à ce
pays, allant jusqu'à se considérer comme
la «première irakienne», et reste installée
à Bagdad jusqu'à la fin de sa vie.
Progressivement, cependant, après la création
du pays, on commence à oublier l'importance
qu'elle a eue.
Gertrude se remet à l'archéologie, rassemblant
des collections qui constituent le musée
archéologique de Bagdad, ouvert en 1926.
Elle lutte d'ailleurs pour que les trésors
découverts restent dans le pays et ne partent
pas en Europe.
Elle ne retourne qu'en 1925 au Royaume-Uni,
brièvement, mais déclare ensuite qu'elle
ne veut plus jamais y mettre les pieds sans
qu'on sache trop pourquoi.
Vers la fin de sa vie elle souffrait de pneumonie
chronique, de pleurésie, et surtout ne se
sentait pas trop d'appartenance avec le nouveau
monde apparu après la fin de la guerre.
Bagdad commençait à se moderniser, et le
temps des expéditions était loin derrière
elle.
Elle meurt le 12 juillet 1926, très probablement
en se suicidant au barbiturique pour ne pas
finir ses jours à l'hôpital de Bagdad.
Elle y est enterrée lors de funérailles
militaires, est décorée de l'ordre de l'Empire
britannique, et son testament permet la création
de l’École britannique d'archéologie d'Irak.
Lawrence d'Arabie ne peut pas assister aux
funérailles, car il est en mission en Inde
à ce moment là, mais écrit une lettre à
sa famille sur laquelle je terminerai cette
vidéo.
Et j'espère qu'elle vous a plu.
«Je pense qu'elle est heureuse dans la
mort.
Car son œuvre politique était achevé, comme
la mienne.
L'Irak est une belle construction.
Même si cela ne dure que quelques années
comme je le crains, et parfois l'espère.
Un gouvernement, c'est un cadeau douteux à
donner à des gens qui n'en ont jamais eu.
Bien sûr, c'est vous qui êtes les plus malheureux
de ne plus avoir Gertrude, mais enfin, elle
n'était pas à vous.
Enthousiaste, intéressée, toujours passionnée
par les rencontres et les événements du
jour, elle laissait une impression de perpétuelle
fraîcheur.
Plus exactement, quelle que fut sa fatigue,
elle restait capable d'intéresser, et de
capter l'attention de quiconque venait la
voir.
Je ne pense pas avoir jamais connu personne
qui fut si totalement civilisé.»